to to ask you about another piece of
technology
AI that has the potential to have a um
various
trajectories uh to have an impact on
human civilization H how do you think AI
will change
us we you're talking about you know
generative AI large language models
things like Chad GPT and its soon
successors and
um these are incredibly powerful
Technologies to believe otherwise is to
bury her head in the sand soon to be
even more
powerful
um it's interesting to me that that
large language models in their current
form are not inventions they're
discoveries you know the telescope was
an
invention but looking through it at
Jupiter knowing that it had moons was a
discovery like my God it has
moons and that's what Galileo did and so
this is closer on that spectrum of
invention you know we know exactly what
happens with a 787 it's an engineered
object we designed it we know how it
behaves we don't want any
surprises um large language models are
much more like discoveries we're
constantly getting surprised by their
capabilities they're not really
engineered
objects um then you know you have
this debate about whether they're going
to be good for Humanity or bad for
Humanity um you know even specialized AI
can be very bad for Humanity I mean I
just you know just regular machine
learning models that can can make you
know certain weapons of war that could
be incredibly destructive and very
powerful and they're not General AIS
they're just they could just be very
smart
weapons
um and so we have to think about all of
those
things ju I'm very optimistic about this
so even in the face of all this
uncertainty
my own view is that that these powerful
tools are much more likely to help us
and save us even than they are to on
balance hurt us and destroy us I think
you know we humans have a lot of ways of
um we can make ourselves go extinct you
know these things may help us not do
that you know so we may actually they
actually save us so the people who are
you know over overly concerned I in my
view overly concerned it's a valid
debate um I I think that I I think that
they may be missing part of the equation
which is how helpful they could be in
making sure we don't destroy
ourselves um I don't know if you saw the
movie
Oppenheimer but to me I first of all I
loved the movie and I thought the best
part of the movie is this bureaucrat
played by Robert Downey Jr who you know
some people have talked to think that's
the most boring part of the movie I
thought it was the most fascinating
because what's going on here is you
realize we have invented these awesome
destructive powerful Technologies called
nuclear weapons and they are managed and
you know we we we humans are we're not
really capable of wielding those weapons
yeah we're you know that's what he
represented in that movie is here's this
guy who is uh just he wrongly thinks
he's like being so petty he thinks that
he said something that Oppenheimer said
something bad to Einstein about him they
didn't talk about him at all as you find
out in the final scene of the movie and
yet he's spent his career trying to be
vengeful and uh and Petty and that's
that's the problem we as a species
are not
really sophisticated enough and mature
enough to handle these Technologies and
so and and by the way before you get to
General Ai and the possibility of AI
having agency and there's a lot of
things would have to happen but um
there's so much benefit that's going to
come from these Technologies in the
meantime even before their you know
General AI in terms of better medicines
and uh better tools to develop more
Technologies and so on so I think it's
an incredible moment to be alive and to
witness the Transformations that are
going to happen how quickly will happen
no one knows but over the next 10 years
and 20 years I think we're going to see
really remarkable advances and I
personally am very excited about it
first of all really interesting to say
that it's Discovery is that it's true
that we don't know the
limits of what's possible uh with the
current language models we don't and
like it could be a few tricks and hacks
here and there that that uh open doors
to hold entire new possibilities we do
know that humans are doing something
different um from these models in part
because you know we're so power
efficient you know the human brain does
remarkable things and it does it on
about 20 watts of power and you know uh
the the AI techniques we use today use
many kilowatts of power to do equivalent
tasks so there's something interesting
about the way the human brain does this
and also we don't need as much data so
you know like self-driving cars are they
have to drive billions and billions of
miles to try and to learn how to drive
and you know your average 16-year-old uh
figures it
out with many fewer miles so there are
still some tricks I think that we have
yet to learn I don't think we've learned
the last trick I don't think it's just a
question of scaling things up um but
what's interesting is that just scaling
things up and I put just in quotes
because it's actually hard to scale
things up but just scaling things up
also appears to pay huge dividends yeah
and and it's there's some more nuanced
aspect about human beings that's
interesting if it's able to accomplish
like being truly original and novel to
you know large language models being
able to come up with something
truly new
ideas uh that's one and the other one is
uh truth it seems that large language
models are very good at
sounding like they're saying a true
thing but they don't uh require or often
have a grounding in sort of a
mathematical truth it can just basically
is a very good bullshitter so if if
there's not enough dat if there's not
enough sort of data uh in the in the
training data about a particular topic
is just going to
concoct um accurate sounding narratives
which is a very fascinating problem to
try to solve how do you get uh language
models to infer what is true and not to
sort of introspect yeah they need to be
taught to say I don't know more often
yeah and uh I know several humans who
could be taught that as well sure and
then the other stuff cuz you're still a
bit involved in the Amazon side with the
AI things the other open question is
what kind of products are created from
this oh so many yeah I mean you know
just to you know we have um Alexa and
Eko and Alexa has you know hundreds of
millions of installed base you know
inputs and so there's this there's you
know there's Alexa everywhere and guess
what Alexa is about to get a lot smarter
yeah and so that's really you know from
a product point of view that's super
exciting there's so many opportunities
there so many opportunities shopping
assistant you know like all that stuff
is amazing in AWS you know we're
building Titan which is our foundational
model we're also building um Bedrock
which our corporate clients at
AWS our Enterprise clients they want to
be able to use these powerful models
with their own corporate data yes
without accidentally contributing their
corporate data to that model yes and so
those are the tools we're building for
them with bedrock so there's tremendous
opportunity here yeah the security the
Privacy all those things are fascinating
of how to cuz so much value can be
gained by training on private data but
you want to keep this secure that's a
it's a fascinating technical problem
this this is a very challenging
technical problem and it's one that
we're you know making progress on and
dedicated to solving for our
customers uh do you think there will be
a day when humans and robots maybe Alexa
have a romantic relationship like can be
her well I mean you look at
brainstorming products here if you look
at the Spectrum of human variety and
what people like you know sexual variety
yes you know they're people who like
everything so the answer your question
has to be yes I don't know I don't know
how widespread that will be all right
but it will happen I was just asking
when for a friend but it's all right I
just moving
on